what up
why why is your voice like that
hello
let's get ready to all right what's
going on with jay powell all right talk
normally i don't like that jerome jerome
jerome as much as people were hoping for
a soft landing jerome told the people
that we just
a soft landing is going to be very
challenging and that a recession
is certainly a possibility
what
that was the market crashing and ending
in a explosion soft landing is going to
be challenging of course we've been
talking about this it is so difficult to
balance between high inflation coming
down but not getting a recession it's
like a tightrope walk yeah sure maybe
there's one or two people in the world
who could do it but for the most part it
is not possible so ultimately they have
a choice either we live with high
inflation
or we live with a recession if they are
not careful we could get both in a
stagflation situation now of course jay
powell he's actually started to become
much more transparent about what
transpired over the last couple of
months
wasn't transitory true he now is saying
it isn't transitory congratulations we
agree he also
is saying that inflation is not because
of russia's invasion of ukraine he was
recently asked about that and said i do
not believe that because inflation was
already high before russia invaded
ukraine i wish our politicians would say
the same
last but not least
jay powell is now talking about the fact
that if they are going to destroy demand
it likely will lead to some sort of
recessionary type event and so you have
a choice inflation recession
hope you don't get both we're gonna see
what happens in the united states of
america
i
do not believe
that inflation will come down i don't
think we'll see less than i don't know
the fed says less than five percent
inflation by the end of the year
that's kind of crazy
and also i think that we are headed in
to a recession or some sort of deep bear
market
and so
unless they pivot unless they reverse
course
prepare yourselves my friend so we're
going into the bear cave
wait okay i have a question like a bear
market
yeah like the bears in the bear yeah but
bears go into hibernation
bulls don't
okay um so my question is do you
remember when you said that like as they
were pumping money into the economy it
wasn't sustainable but they would have
to keep doing it because they had no
other choice so but they're not i had
another choice
but you said they would keep doing it
but no they're not
so if you go back to march of 2020
there's a liquidity crisis they had that
was the first choice they had they said
everyone go home government today not
the central bank government
central bank looks at the at the board
right they're playing the game looking
at the board asset prices are all
falling people are all fearful what do
we do the first choice they have
intervene
or stay out of the way they chose to
intervene
once they choose to intervene they are
faced with a second choice
mitigate short-term pain at the expense
of a long-term problem
or we will intervene over a longer time
frame but will take the pain now in the
short term
they chose to not only intervene but
also to mitigate the short-term pain and
so now we are dealing with the longer
term problem which is very high
inflation they have a third choice along
the way which is when do they stop the
loose monetary policy
in november
and december december inflation was
seven percent in america
they were still
at zero percent interest rates and they
were still conducting quantitative
easing
so it's like driving towards a wall
and rather than at some point like oh
shoot i'm gonna hit the wall and try to
slam on the brakes and not hit it
they were actually still accelerating
into the problem
so that was the third
then they were faced with a fourth
decision
when do we actually go ahead and pivot
from loose monetary policy they chose to
start to do that earlier this year
interest rates started to rise they now
are trying to conduct quantitative
easing or quantitative tightening so
they have a fifth decision that's coming
up
when will they stop
and they continue to say they're not
going to stop they're going to keep
going until basically something breaks
we'll see
i don't know if they actually will do
that
it's going to be pretty hard to continue
to break things and have people lose
money going into a midterm election yeah
you can't just break things and then
think it's okay there's no playing ball
in the house
oh
it's true
okay
uh
powell also mentioned that crypto needs
to be regulated
it is regulated no
more regulated more regulated is uh uh
up for debate but it is regulated well
he said it needs to have the same
regulation as other financial products
that already exist
uh it does
okay you told g pal that i'm not i'm
just a messenger no what they want is
they want additional i would argue that
crypto in some cases is more regulated
than the latest fighters
in the state of new york where new york
city is the financial capital of the
world if you want to start a fintech
company you have less licenses to get
than if you want to start a crypto
business interesting and so if you have
to get more licenses
and of course the bit license they don't
give out a ton of them
then it's actually harder to start a
crypto company in new york city the
financial capital of the world than it
is to start a fintech company
and so
again that's one of many many different
ways you could evaluate it but in that
specific situation
it's more regulated now what do most
companies do they say we're not going to
serve new york we'll go somewhere else
and so the second thing is the taxation
if i go spend dollars or any other fiat
currency
i don't get hit with capital gains tax
if i spend bitcoin or cryptocurrency to
buy dinner or buy a good or service i
get hit with capital gains tax it is a
more onerous taxation of these
instruments now what i think he's
talking about and where i do think that
there will be more regulation is around
disclosures around what's a security
what's not a security right so it's part
of the industry it's already more
regulated another part of the industry
is not more regulated and that's
probably what he's talking about but the
clarity of where do we need more
regulation is probably an important well
and they are working on that bipartisan
bill correct so
there are a number of different efforts
yes more all right what's going on with
revlon
revlon
so
voluntarily filed for bankruptcy on june
16th the stock tumbled to 13.3 percent
to close at 1.95 dollars
but
it then soared 47.9 in the afternoon
trading wednesday it has now rocketed
359 percent
since then since i filed for bankruptcy
so revlon it appears as the new meme
stock that all these like retail traders
are fueling to go to the moon
my question is
at this point if you're a company in
trouble
do you hope to become a mean stock
i think that it doesn't matter because
it's not like they're if they already
filed for bankruptcy my guess is that
that's not going to change their outlook
of are you in bankruptcy or are you not
it may change some of the the details or
the restructuring uh kind of mechanisms
but i don't think that it actually
changes uh whether they're gonna be in
um
uh in bankruptcy if this had happened
before they filed for bankruptcy and
they were able to do some sort of uh
equity offering or something like that
then it could have changed it but unless
there's some detail i don't know the
story for example hertz also filed for
bankruptcy in may 2020 but then after
the stock started soaring it had
recovered everything that lost in the
post-bankruptcy sell-off in just a
couple weeks and it eventually exited
from bankruptcy on july 1st 2021 so it
is possible to emerge well you come out
i mean every company that goes into
bankruptcy the whole point is that you
basically get protection it's like call
off the dogs you go through a
restructuring and then you come out of
bankruptcy the question is just what are
the details and if you if your stock is
exploding upwards then you're able to
raise more capital it may be more
attractive to certain investors all that
stuff that's interesting okay all right
what's up in the metaverse mark
zuckerberg appeared on jim cramer's show
on wednesday and said that the metaverse
could be a considerable part of the
social network's operators oh my god the
social network operator's business in
the second half of the decade so
basically zuck said that we hope to
basically get around a billion people in
the metaphors doing hundreds of dollars
of commerce
buying digital goods digital content
different things to express themselves
clothing whatever becoming more
productive and then that's how he's
going to make money
he changed the name of his company from
facebook to meta anyone thinking
you think this well maybe not
how's that going
well i mean if you if here's a big
question
is uh bitcoin considered part of the
metaverse probably yes digital currency
virtual currency is that what they would
use in the metaverse
uh it depends who you ask if you ask the
bitcoiners they're already using it in
the metabolism twitter is a low fidelity
version of the metaverse and you're
using bitcoin there to do tipping
so bitcoin has already won one use case
in the metaverse i have a question yeah
if you had to get a job in the metaverse
what would it be
in the metaverse yeah is my real
identity attached to it or not not i'd
be a stripper
let's go
i mean if your real identity is not
attached to it why because you probably
that would probably be a very high
income but you would have to like put on
the goggles and you would have to dance
no yes no you could just use ai and just
like have a character dancing and then
you would get the money you know that's
what i'm saying it's not tied to your
real identity well mine would be a
billionaire oh
is that a job or is that an end state
it's an occupation really
it's a way of life it's a lifestyle
thank you math tell me you're not a
billionaire why not tell me you're not a
billionaire
all right okay speaking of people won't
know what my stripper name would be no
what's it what's charity
switch topics here
number one
charitable giving in the united states
it reached a record
485 billion dollars in 2021 though the
increase did not keep pace with
inflation
wow
that's a lot
that yeah
this is so that's a record setting no
again let me uh let me pull back the
curtain a little bit for a lot of folks
uh
i would have to look at all the details
my guess is a huge contributing factor
is if asset prices are at all time highs
there's a lot of folks who usually would
donate assets not cash
and therefore let's say that your stock
is worth a hundred dollars if now is
worth 200
to you it's still hey i'm donating one
share of stock and so is it being 200
worth rather than 100 worth and so i
think that there's some of that at play
also if
profits of companies are exploding if
income is going up if assets are going
up and people are selling them to get
cash uh that means that they have higher
tax bills and so there's also some of
the charitable contribution stuff going
there and then last but not least is
that there's also a lot of screwed up
stuff happening in the world and via
social media and the internet more and
more people have been onboarded to
various charitable platforms uh and it's
become a thing to give money uh to these
causes via the internet and so it
drastically increases the uh addressable
market what do they mean that it hasn't
kept up with inflation
well what was it the year before
what was charitable giving like it's
just maybe this way if charitable giving
uh was a hundred dollars in uh 2020 yeah
and then
december of 2021 it was 105 that's up
five percent but inflation's up seven
yeah then actually you could argue that
the charities have negative growth
so donations were technically four
percent higher than 2020 but they were
down 0.7 percent when adjusted for
inflation wow so wild okay it's almost
like i kind of sort of
think inflation's a big deal
yes
single most important issue in america
right now all right what's up with the
illegal party okay
walton county in florida oh i saw this
story there were hundreds of teenagers
250 of them who broke in and burglarized
a five bedroom eight bath eight million
dollar home this weekend
and they went in they they had um like a
boxing match
then people were like
i mean it was had a banger it looked
like it was the fact that it looks fun
if i was in high school but the fact
that it took them so long to like some
for somebody to call the cops for a like
a noise complaint
it's pretty wild uh when i was in high
school i can't say who uh
names but uh there was a kid his parents
went out of town and he told like a
couple of people he was like yeah i'm
gonna go to the movies and then uh why
don't you guys come over
and of course it's high school it's like
the word spreads you know like wild mean
girls and so he went to the movies he
came back there were so many people at
his house that he called the cops on his
own house
honestly
i remember being like you did what he
was like bro there's like you know
whatever a bunch of people and i was
like man that's crazy uh and i feel like
that's how those events happen is that
like somebody's like oh my friend is
like leaving or whatever somebody's like
let's go over there and then word
spreads like wildfire next you know 200
people show up deputies said they have
spoken to some of the teens and the dean
said that they didn't realize the house
was being burglarized see
they just thought it was like hey house
the banger had an 8 million home no but
like
in high school i feel like that's a
thing is that not burglarizing homes but
like
like hey where's the party this weekend
and sometimes it's like oh a friend of a
friend's uh having a party yeah i'm sure
so you go to the house but you actually
don't know who owns the house somebody
started it well that person probably is
going to be in trouble yes but at the
same time you know sometimes wild yeah
see look patrick honeycutt said i
literally did that pom probably talking
about calling the cops on his own house
or being a stripper in the meadowverse
okay
and i love the people who are like
that's not an event it's breaking the
law
yeah it's called burglary wait um i have
i was thinking about something this
morning that i wanted to talk about on
lunch money because i have a platform
now um
so
do you want to hear another party story
our our daughter wow that's so weird to
say our daughter anyway our daughter
said that
she she got a new toy phone which like
has a handle and you like
you know pick it up to talk to people so
i was trying to show her how to use it
but then i was thinking like
you and i but mainly you when he does
calls he puts it on speakerphone so
there is no like even hey because i
don't want the 5g getting in my brain oh
okay well it's it's all speakerphone so
i'm like kidding when she grows up she's
gonna be like i don't know there's no
well you you are showing her a landline
right like
punching in the number like i know but
it's just crazy that it doesn't exist
anymore and then i saw this video on
instagram that was like they were asking
adults like us
what do you do what hand motion do you
do when somebody says telephone and they
do this and then they ask like gen z and
then like i don't know like this
because there's no you know it's like
they have this
it's crazy anyway i thought it was cool
i feel like you're an old soul i am an
old soul all right all right can i ask
one more question why are people saying
ronaldo yes uh because cristiano ronaldo
uh is doing a deal with binance oh
he did a whole video
very very well known famous uh uh
footballer um can i ask two questions
real quick before we let you go first is
uh
when you go on the internet
what are the three top websites that you
go to me yeah for me it's definitely
google email and twitter what are yours
sub stack email
and twitter
yeah i was thinking about the other day
i'm shocked
that i understand tick tock is uh is the
number one site google's up there i'm
always shocked that there's not more
reports about email
being uh one of the the uh most visited
old people new people or young people
new people young people just
snapchat their way to
life is a message
okay uh and then the um the second
question i have for you is uh now that
we have a a public audience
will you watch
the new adam sandler movie with me on
netflix also yes i've been wanting to
tell the people what you think about
adam sandler i do not like adam sandler
at all blasphemous
but i heard i literally made polina i
literally made her sit down before
sophia showed up i made plenty to sit
down with a sense of humor and i made
her watch big daddy and i said this is
what fatherhood looks like to me this is
my education of fatherhood is big daddy
but have you seen adam stanley in like
50 first dates and like along came
paulie it was here those aren't adam
sandler movies those are like other
movies where he was like i need a bag
because i probably want to like go buy
cocaine or something oh god and so he
was like let me just go ahead and do the
movies i can get some cash adam sandler
movies there are very specific movies
big daddy and billy madison are probably
two water boy three i mean like those
three movies for me not for me cause you
don't have a sense of humor yeah that's
exactly you don't understand good acting
uh-huh
water boy
i'm good
you're trying
you're trying to explain to me that
water boy is not a good happy gilmore
happy gimbal that's another one i mean
the guy's a legend he's a hit machine
i could sit for an entire day and just
watch the greatest hits of adam sandler
and i if i died that night i'd die happy
wow
no billy madison
what are you looking at swan
you say that all the time
because it's an amazing movie
water
you know who who
you can't you don't even know the names
of other actors that are half as good as
that reese witherspoon
legally blonde
uh
see ya all right guys thank you so much
i appreciate it playing friends hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time